it's about as far as you can get from
Syria and yet here in the Russian town
of Catawba people are waiting for news
about seven locals who reportedly went
to fight in Syria they allegedly worked
as mercenaries which is illegal in
Russia the topic is sensitive many
people here say they know nothing about
the men in fact we are repeatedly met
with rejection and killed over this
building is home to the mother of one of
the fighters she had agreed to speak to
us about her son but cancelled the
interview after being told her son had
been killed a local gives us the address
of the wife of another mercenary when we
tried to speak to her she insists she is
someone else but she also warns none of
us is going to talk to you just like the
relatives of the mercenaries the Russian
government has largely kept silent about
them and even denied their existence
the Foreign Ministry took over a week to
respond after a recent airstrike
reportedly killed up to 200 Russians
reports about the death of dozens and
hundreds of Russian citizens it's a
classic case of disinformation according
to preliminary data we could be talking
about the death of five people
presumably Russian citizens as a result
of an armed clash the causes of which we
are currently investigating done and I
see analyst young brunette ski thinks
the Russian government is using
mercenary groups to keep official
military losses low but you want the
good news
this strategy is beneficial for the
Russian government because it can show
it's doing its job but just like the
Americans and the British Russia can say
those aren't our soldiers no soldiers
have died we don't know who these people
are
ask whoever sent them there to educated
on a prior in the run-up to the
presidential elections news about the
death of Russian soldiers is
inconvenient for the government here
even from kid rover this small town in
the Urals seven men reportedly joined a
private Russian military company to
fight in Syria the town's population is
Stover mm although no relatives wanted
to talk on camera other residents were
willing to speak about the men gusta he
was a good boy he wasn't a thug who
didn't care about anything he was a good
boy
maybe he wanted to earn money towards an
apartment there's not much work here
asana
yeah the muga sawdust so to get any
better us by Yahoo I think the
government is behind all of this it's
not like these guys just decided to go
there themselves and just went
someone must have sent them but private
little rat problem it's not clear when
and if the men in Syria will return
ticket Rover for now the town and the
government are both keeping their
silence